scholastic has published goosebumps the
Magic School Bus and animorphs and now
it's taking on Ubisoft's assassin's
creed franchise with an all-new young
adult book series we might not be
getting a big Assassin's Creed game this
year but at least we're getting a new
stories the series called last
descendants will be written by Matthew J
Kirby the award-winning author of ice
fall book one is scheduled to release
the sep tember with a second on the way
in January 2017 it's said to be an
action filled adventure with protagonist
Owen entering simulated memories from
his DNA just like how these sessions
Creed games work he'll be adventuring
through both 1860s New York and the
ancient Aztec empire it might not be the
assassins creed adventure you were
looking for in 2016 but last descendant
sounds like it will be an engaging read
if we get our hands on the book or hear
more about the story you can read all
about it on gamespot and for all the
assassins creed news you need you're
already in the right place